this lamborghini costs more than your
house listen to it purr
oh oh my gosh it's angry and i have 100
minecraft players here whichever one of
them builds the most epic car gets the
real lamborghini what server disperse
the players
and now all 100 minecraft players have
their own plot of land the age of
dragons what is going on here this is
going to be a very big lightning mcqueen
yeah
yes you don't need to say anything else
congratulations
i just want to let you know these two
judges here they're biased they like
cartoons i gotta be the equalizer oh my
god if this guy is making the mystery
machine no no no here's the thing jimmy
the mystery machine is a car it is a car
come on there's a lambo on the line bro
start building what if someone builds
multiple cars chris do we dock points do
or do we add points hey
deathpanda1024 hi what's your strategy
lamborghini on the line i'm just kind of
rolling with it hey he's rolling with it
get it hey it's a car challenge hey
contestants i have a lamborghini and one
of you is getting it you know what i
like more than my lamborghini knowledge
oh i haven't seen anybody else building
a car like this cola cal what are your
thoughts on this build this is the most
expensive thing i'm ever gonna screw up
confidence have you seen how nice the
lamborghini looks is it the tractor you
thought it was the lamborghini tractor
from the mystery box video no it's
actually the lamborghini that was to the
left of it i'm gonna try my
all right let's go
[Music]
45 minutes remain they're not gonna have
enough time look at this guy he's
redoing his whole build he has 45
minutes he's got it i'll see it when i
believe it
banana car you wanna see something fun
yeah so badly
troll face this car is terrifying it's
the carl car okay yo
is this a giant burger car oh it's a
paddy wagon it's the party wagon oh god
hey what are you making here what is
this i am making the spongebob car okay
also no pickles for chandler he's not
even here chandler slept in oh well in
that case i'll add pickles yeah please
add pickles holy crap look at all these
cars look they're making so much
progress check this out i think this is
creative they made toy cars yo look this
guy's got a whole road look at this
notice how every plot is just grey
concrete except this guy he hasn't even
started making a car yet i have a very
cool surprise for the contestants can
you guess it i bet it's annoying this is
so stupid there's now llamas everywhere
oh my god every contestant has a llama
watch i'll do it again
now everyone has three llamas make the
llamas part of your build how do you
make llamas part of a car make them
drive it oh my god it's the baby car can
we make the baby car win please guys go
up to a random person and just stare at
him uh right
okay
i just cleared their inventory wait no
wait you cleared everybody's inventory
you're so mean how much time is left 30
minutes holy guac what if i just keep
clearing their inventory like this that
would make you a jerk this guy's just
going from car to car with his llama
showing it around no wait they're
stealing everyone's llamas polly pockets
69 someone just stole a llama from polly
pocket 69. it's a llama steel llama take
world we thought this was a car building
competition but we actually spawned the
llama mafia la mafia
hope as lol what are you building a
futuristic spaceship whoever builds the
best car wins not spaceship oh it's like
a flying car there you go more
importantly where's your llamas they
went away
[Music]
there's 20 minutes left in the
competition and this is everything built
so far this looks insane what the heck
guys guys guys guys guys now i know why
no one has their llamas anymore this
dude went on a spree and just collected
everyone's llamas all right i just gave
everyone nausea oh my dude this is
actually going to give me irl nausea
more nausea yo
diamond lamborghini with diamond llama
isn't it weird that nobody's made a
tesla i'm literally flying up to a tesla
as you say that everybody you got 10
minutes left and then one of you is
getting a lamborghini
lamborghini gentlemen
what do these look like uh just normal
minecraft cards you can drive them
wait why are you faster why is mine the
slowest
why sure is faster because i was built
for speed mike looks like a transformer
mid sneeze
oh i've gone so fast i'm stuck it's been
an hour and the baby car is still the
exact same as it should be we have
precisely
162 seconds left whoa
not my first rodeo this isn't a rodeo
this is building cars
anyone want my friends this guy made a
transformer he thought he was really
doing something too i feel kind of bad
five oh four oh time is up oh
and before we judge the 100 creations
carl what are you judging on pandering
that's probably gonna piss some people
off what about you chris bonnie i'm
gonna judge on originality and effort oh
what
up first we have nico overlord's mini
lambo there are llamas piloting it
that's a couple extra points i'm gonna
give it a four oh and it's stick shift
oh five that's a five i'm gonna give it
a six that means they got a 16. probably
not gonna win on that one but good luck
up next we have the monster truck
it's cool but they had a lot of time
there's just a lot of dead space here
yeah there's no interior either oh yeah
i'm giving it a four there's not even an
interior four uh i'll give it a four so
this is the school bus it's the magic
school bus here's the thing the interior
it's a little lackluster it is really
cool though i'm gonna give it a seven
they pandered well seven and i the voice
of reason i'm not gonna give in i'm
gonna give it a five just because they
made a car from a cartoon doesn't mean
it's high effort oh the sesame steeds he
put the sesame seeds like the llamas are
riding in there and they're named
patrick and spongebob that's pretty
creative oh there's
come down here
gary i just really like how he took care
of the llamas and named them i'm gonna
give it a six i'm giving it an eight
yeah this is an eight well then that
brings his total up to 22 putting him in
first place this car actually looks
really dope but on top of that it has a
battle bus what does the battle must do
john fortnite that's why there's about a
bus i wish to ask something of you yes
sir i've been trying to do something
with tom meonick i wish for him to
respond to my friendship application
everyone spam this at tommy until he
does whatever he just said anyways if it
was just this car i'd give it a seven
but he also added the battle bus so i'm
gonna make it seven and a half i was
teetering between an eight and a nine i
couldn't decide what first of all
there's some random graveyard for no
reason okay you know what carl swayed me
you're getting a five it's all carl's
fault okay i'll give you a nine that
brings this total up to 21 and a half
half under oh and if you forgot what the
card they're competing for looks like
here you go and here's what it sounds
like
this isn't a game this is one of the few
actual cars and i like how the llamas
make kind of like the yeah the horde of
it lamborghini that's actually good oh
no there's not even a oh now he's
getting like a five there's not even a
bottom to the car there's not even an
engine in this car it's just got a bunch
of llamas on it five next and now for
the moment you've all been waiting for
the baby car let's go
chris what do you rate it ten i give it
a zero to ten it can't win even though
it can't win i'm also giving it a zero
out of ten stormy climber what did you
run out of time could you not finish the
top of your car maybe it is a
cheeseburger right it is so why is it
burger but then also chicken we were
having an egg battle maybe if you spent
less time having an egg fight and more
time building your burger car you'd have
a finished burger car i knew i wasn't
gonna win storm climber at least you won
the viewer's hearts i am proud i can do
that oh my gosh this one's really cool
more ammo tell us about your build it's
a wagon of sorts that's powered by
llamas oh my gosh that's so genius yo
that's cool i like the wheels the wheels
are creative ammo if you could rate this
vehicle what would you rate it out of
ten round and eight i'm gonna give it a
nathan this is easily the most creative
this is my nine nine that puts you at a
26er which means you're in first place
oh
jimmy
this is easily one of the most creative
builds jimmy all the llamas are the
different people and then look they even
have scooby-doo did they put name tags
on them honestly if they would have
named them i'm nailing the coffin would
have been perfect no look in here
oh
10 done i really want to give it a
perfect score but they just didn't name
the llama so i'm gonna give it a eight
duffkins on a scale one to ten how epic
do you think this is it's like it's 7.5
all right well my vote's a 7.5 which put
you half a point below the other person
in first place
do you not trust yourself on your
epicness man this is pretty epic i'm
devastated more ammo do you know why i
just moved you back to call i came in
second actually you came in third ah and
by third place i mean first place you
just won a brand new lamborghini oh my
god we are now back at the lamborghini
and i have ammo on discord ammo can you
hear me again here's your brand new
lamborghini
i can't even hear him it's so loud
what what do you think of the car i
can't even speak right now send me your
address and i'm gonna pay someone to
drive this to you and to you guys
watching make sure you hit that
subscribe button because we're gonna
give someone a thousand dollars in the
next seven days that subscribes
literally just press it are you hungry
good because as you know i have my own
nationwide restaurant chain and for a
limited time we just did a burger collab
with dream that's right dream just made
a burger and added it to our menu go on
grubhub ubereat store dash wherever you
order food and go order a mr beastburger
right now